I'm the most famous person here this is
a really illegal video I'm gonna bring
how's it going everybody it's Warren and
we have our first behind-the-scenes
video for Avengers endgame and as you
just saw it does not come from Marvel
Studios it does not come from Disney it
comes from Chris Pratt it's a really
really cool video really cool look at
the behind the scenes with all of these
super famous actors together in one
scene no doubt filming the final battle
of Avengers endgame and as it turns out
this is kind of an illegal video that
Chris Pratt took he said that nobody was
allowed to film any things or take any
pictures on their phones but he was so
blown away by all of the awesome people
in one room in one scene that he had to
film something when he posted this to
Instagram he said I remember being blown
away in this moment on the Avengers set
nobody was allowed to film anything on
their phones I said screw it no rule was
going to stop me from seizing this
once-in-a-lifetime opportunity to
capture this collection of stars a group
that likely will never be in the same
room again we are so blessed this is
typical Chris Pratt fashion like you
said not letting a rule stand in his way
of seizing an opportunity and what an
opportunity we have in this video Dave
Bautista Don Cheadle nebula and Gamora
stanzin we have Chris Pratt of course
who is filming we have what looks like
to be Anthony Russo Paul Rudd Jeremy
Renner Chris Hemsworth sebastian stan
chadwick boseman we have palm Mark
Ruffalo Joe Russo Danai gurira
Tom Holland Robert Downey jr. and what
looks to be Gwyneth Paltrow to his left
Tessa Thompson a stand-in for dr.
strange and Sean Gunn so again what an
awesome video first time we get a look
behind the scenes of Avengers endgame
thanks to the one and only Chris Pratt
Avengers in game truly was an amazing
movie and we can expect more videos like
this to come to light the further we get
along in fact some of the other actors
replied to Chris Pratt's sharing this
video with they took some of their own
so we can expect those to probably come
to light very soon but let me know what
you think about this video I thought you
all would like it let me know what your
favorite part was of Avengers endgame
and let me know how many times you have
seen it so far let me know in the
comments down below and a reminder about
my giveaway I'm giving away a life-sized
Infinity Gauntlet and a glow-in-the-dark
famous painting by glow by beau you can
also check out some of his other work at
glow by beau comm I'll put the link in
the description down below all you have
to do to enter for your chance to win is
be subscribed to my channel like this
video and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero or
villain I'll be picking a new winner at
the end of the month as always thank you
all so much for watching
woof woof
relations to your desperation to save
the universe you killed half of its
population yeah you did it very Nass and
all it took
you said it cost you everything while
crying like a baby now your number